well I think in some ways the young
artists today are finding their
inspiration as much in pop culture in
those little areas in pop culture where
people are still doing serious work and
the reason is because that's the only
culture that's accessible to them now
you have some people like especially
with musicians where there's still a
viable kind of classical tradition they
can they could become part of an
orchestra and they can learn the
repertory and things like this but young
artists i think learn from the art that
came before them and the circumstances
of their own lives and so I think it's
always been the case but I think today a
lot of artists are more in the present
moment than they are with any kind of
vivifying relationship with the past and
you can do good things out of that but I
think it's actually would a richer way
to be able to pull from the president
the past together